I think it was maybe a 2016 paper where
the scientists talk about this research
and they just sort of throw out the term
hope molecules when you contract your
muscles in any type of movement they are
secreting chemicals into your
bloodstream that are really good for
every system of your body I mean they're
great for your heart health and your
immune function and some of them can
kill cancer cells you know all the stuff
we know exercise is good for so you go
for a walk or a run or you lift weights
and your muscles contract and they
secrete these proteins into your
bloodstream and in your brain they can
act as an antidepressant they can make
your brain more resilient to stress they
increase motivation they help you learn
from experience when I go for a walk or
I exercise I will literally say to
myself
you're giving yourself an intravenous
dose of Hope like I think this is how we
should frame movement that that it's
something you can choose to do to really
powerfully influence your mental health